are you about to tell me to wait in the
car
how to say all that what you think i
can't with the zone
you got nothing to prove to me okay
but i have something to prove to me
that is actress simone mystic as
detective misty knight in marvel's luke
cage she was marvel's first black female
superhero on tv and now she is back for
the new season of all rise on own she
plays judge lola carmichael in the
courtroom drama in this clip judge
carmichael is in the process of
approving a plea deal when her ex
interrupts the court proceedings
the defendant has agreed to accept three
years of summary probation penalties
totaling five thousand dollars a
three-month court-approved alcohol
education program and restitution to the
injured party is that correct excuse the
interruption your honor
but i think we could come up with more
favorable terms mr
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you so much for being here thank
you so this is the first season where
you are executive producers yes
congratulations on that thank you what's
the best part and what's the biggest
difference between just being the lead
to being having this behind the scenes
role the best part is being able to
support everyone
in a real way you know you
always advocate i always advocate for my
actors and for everyone on our crew we
have an amazing crew but now they
actually listen to me uh so i've gotten
to hire some amazing actors that you
know might not have even gotten in the
door sometimes uh the biggest difference
is all the emails it's literally
constantly like we're on set i'm looking
at an edit and sending notes or i'm on a
call in between a take in order to
listen to what our own executives have
to tell us and uh it that new
partnership is wonderful so it's just a
little bit a little bit more work but a
lot more fun that sounds like amazing to
have that ownership so you just
mentioned own own picked up all rise and
of course own his run by oprah
so she i heard was part of your table
read for you know rehearsals we're to
actually let's play our let's play that
that tape right now
when we
you know look at this beautiful cast and
the work that you all have done led by
the force herself miss
misik
there was no choice but to say yes
all
rise
immediately can i just say i mean
very few people have had the honor of
being part of an oprah
come on
opera
opera moment that should be something i
read that oprah was on one of your
vision boards growing up oh my goodness
so i literally just pulled this out a
couple days ago just to look at it she's
on the vision board because she's miss
winfrey it's like of course she's on a
vision board but never in my wildest
prayers did i realize that it was going
to come together in that way and there
are so many things on that vision board
that have come to fruition which is
amazing so many things that have
happened for my husband and i'm like wow
i didn't i didn't see that part of the
vision but you know they call it the
tetris effect of like what you see and
what you you know constantly run your
mind over can be what you can achieve
and i just believe that i praise god
that
miss winfrey is now my boss which is
beautiful you know i don't think it's a
coincidence because your your mind is
working on things subconsciously also
even if you're not directing it or don't
feel like you're directing it's there
it's happening those boards do work the
uh i'm really curious about your
character all right so season three we
got a little taste of the kind of i
think you'd call it messiness in her
personal life even as she has it all
buttoned up and together as a judge uh
what other messiness do we have in store
you know
lola is a is a working mom and that
balance for her and her husband can
prove to be a little difficult but then
you add on top of that
adding in an x and and what that does
between her best friends which are
played by wilson bethel and ryan
michelle bethe two amazing actors and
then the people around her who see her
kind of you know taking these missteps
so
uh i it happens in the courtroom as you
can see in this episode that airs
tomorrow and i think that the fans just
really love
seeing lola a little undone even though
they are already dragging me on twitter
and so i'm worried really i am so
worried they're like who is this man get
him out of there your husband
[Laughter]
you have your advisors and they are
literally ride or die they wrote
emails
tweets and what do you host and so much
of that is because of the representation
i mean we just saw katanja brown jackson
she's now on the supreme court what do
you think it means quickly because we're
running out of time for young black and
brown girls to see you as this judge you
know i think if you see it like we said
you can achieve it if you know that
that's possible and for it to happen on
television reaches so many audiences to
then have that real life you can touch
seeing a first black woman as a supreme
court justice that has to inspire it
well thank you so much momsic season
three of all rise airs tuesdays on own
we'll be right back